hot breath what is some of your favorite
or most helpful advice you've gotten
from them
or other comics of their caliber
well i'll tell you it wasn't as much
advice back then
as watching them work you know there's
times when you just shut up and watch
but what i'll tell you what i learned
from george
george always has a pad with him
you will never see george without the
yellow pad and
the lesson was always be writing always
or be ready to write something funny
happens you think of something you see
something
write it down write it down write it
down that's what i got
from george wallace um from dom
it dom stays in the moment dom would
always open in the moment i always like
that
uh say something about what he sees in
the crowd or what just happened but but
it was more just
watching him his comfort on stage his
personality
i remember i remember i think i got from
dom
i was doing my set and i was sitting on
the stool
and he just looked at me what can't
stand for 20 minutes
tired and it was like okay dom i see i
gotta
put a little energy into this um
a great piece of advice i got from
george lopez back then
rodney was in roddy dangerfield was in
and he used to drop in the factory and
do
time or whatever which was amazing you
know but anyway
this woman went on after rodney and she
was talking about rodney like oh rodney
this rodney that right and
george said when a star shows up
never mention them crowd knows who they
are
you got to be who you you got to bring
your you know you got to bring it
yourself you got to show them who you
are
so so there's no sense telling the crowd
that they just saw rodney dangerfield
they know
you know and and uh and and i had a
thing happen with that
sometime later um where
they had a thing called uh it was
chocolate sundaes which is uh like a
black comedy show on sunday night
i've done that and they had
we yeah of course we had um
chris rock and chris tucker
did the show that night and then i had
to go up at like
midnight 12 30. so when you follow both
of them
you know and and it was funny because
both of them talked about
their families and their you know family
asking for money and this and that
and i just went up and said to the crowd
man if i ever make 10 million dollars
and i complain about my family asking
for money you feel free to whip my ass
cracked up on that one but
so so that was some of the advice i got
that that i remembered you know yeah